(upbeat music)
♪ I may be a little kid
♪ But I have been around
♪ Can hear the girls all scream
♪ Soon as our wheels touch down
♪ Junkets in Tokyo
♪ Fashion shoots in Milan
♪ Then a private jet to
Madison Square Garden
♪ 36 week-long tours
♪ 10 singles on the chart
♪ So hear my message girl
♪ 'Cause it comes from the heart
♪ Help me
♪ My parents sold me
♪ To a big producer
in the record industry
♪ He makes me do things
that I don't wanna do
♪ Please call child
services or maybe SVU
♪ You've gotta help me
♪ My parents sold me
♪ To a big producer
♪ In the music industry
♪ They took the cash and left
♪ Me to the screaming masses
♪ If I'd known all this
♪ I'd skip those dancing classes
♪ I tried to run away
♪ One time in Belarus
♪ They beat me with phonebooks
♪ So that I wouldn't bruise
♪ I just can't take no more
♪ Rich kids' bar mitzvahs
♪ Or paid sleepovers
♪ With Saudi princes
♪ Blinked SOS in Morse code
♪ Once at the VMAs
♪ They sprayed me with a hose
♪ In a pit for three days
♪ And when my sales drop off
♪ They'll take me to a resort
♪ And let rich businessmen
♪ Hunt me down for sport
♪ Hold up
♪ I'm just coming in on the song
♪ To check on what
y'all talking about
♪ Oh no
♪ Don't think of
me as a record exec
♪ But a father figure, a pal
♪ Help me
♪ This kid's a real prankster
♪ This is one of
his practical jokes
♪ It's not
♪ Thank you for concern
♪ But there's nothing
to see here, folks
♪ Don't leave
♪ That's just exhaustion talking
♪ Poor little guy's tuckered out
♪ Call the police
♪ I'll take him
back to the tour bus
♪ And we'll get him
straightened out
♪ Don't let him
put me in the box
♪ There is no box
♪ I don't even know
what that means
♪ It's where I sleep
♪ Now we gonna run
but for your trouble
♪ Here's some front-row seats
♪ Gotta help me
♪ My parents sold me
♪ To a big producer
♪ Yeah, we've got a code alert
♪ In the music industry
♪ Oh god, please help me
♪ Please take some action
♪ This didn't work out
for Michael Jackson
♪ Can someone help me
♪ Don't ignore what I said
♪ They'll sacrifice me
to the god bafflement
- The new album
drops on the 42nd!
(all talking)